[MUSIC PLAYING]
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Hello, welcome
to Mobile Web Thursdays.
With me in the studio
today is--
ADDY OSMANI: Addy Osmani.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: We normally
have Paul Kinlan
driving these things.
But he's not here today.
Because unfortunately
he died, or went
on holiday, or something.
I'm not quite sure.
But for whatever reason, I get
to sit in the driving seat.
And it's a pre-record.
So it's OK if I do an
accidental swear.
Because we can just
edit that bit out.
But we're going to try not to.
ADDY OSMANI: Yeah.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: This session is
about mobile web debugging.
So we're going to be looking
how you can use the Web
Inspector on your phone while
looking at Web Inspector on
your desktop, but seeing what's
happening on your
mobile device.
So we may as well jump
straight into it.
I'm learning the ropes of
this whole thing, still.
So the tips I received from last
time is not to just keep
glancing at the camera,
as I'm doing.
People said that was
quite disturbing.
ADDY OSMANI: It Is.
It generally is.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Is it?
ADDY OSMANI: A little
bit creepy.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: People say
that to me in real life--
ADDY OSMANI: I'm
not surprised.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: I look at
them quite disturbing.
Also that I look a bit like
a ghost on camera.
We haven't managed
to fix that.
ADDY OSMANI: He looks like a
ghost in real life, as well.
Don't be too shocked.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: This is a
white piece of paper.
And this is me.
There's nothing I can
do about that.
People who've met me in real
life are just like, you just
look like you on camera.
You were haunting the studio.
Thank you very much for
saying that, guys.
That's brilliant.
OK, let's do some actual stuff
with mobile phones.
ADDY OSMANI: Sounds good.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: So we can get
the view of the mobile device
up and running.
We're working with a Nexus 7.
So I'm going to unlock that.
So if you're going to do mobile
debugging, the first
thing you want to do is go into
the Settings menu, and
down to Developer Options.
There you'll see this
USB debugging.
You want to make sure
that's ticked.
Because you won't be able
to access it otherwise.
And then you need [INAUDIBLE]
setting in Chrome, as well.
We're going to use the beta
version of Chrome.
I think it's pronounced beta.
Or maybe it's beta.
It's just Chrome better.
ADDY OSMANI: It's
Chrome better.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Better
than the other one.
ADDY OSMANI: Yes, that's it.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: So there's a few
new features in the better
version, so we're going
to look at those.
So you need to go into the
Settings menu here, and down
to Developer Tools.
And in there, as well,
you want to
enable USB web debugging.
And from there we can just
browse to a web page.
So I'm going to call up "The
Guardian." Because we can use
that as a use case.
So if I wanted to debug this
page, what I would do is, I'm
going to go onto my
desktop machine.
And this is bit is
a bit of a pain.
I tend to just Google
for Chrome Debug.
And the first link is what
I want to look at.
Actually if I do Chrome Android
debug that's probably
the right one.
Thankfully I have this in
my batch history now.
So I don't have to remember
about it again.
About halfway down the page.
ADDY OSMANI: We've recently
refreshed these docs.
And the process of getting
to Setup is a lot more
straightforward than
it was before.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: What I tend to
do is just copy and paste this
line here into my terminal.
I'm going to do that there.
And that sets everything up.
What it's actually doing is it's
forwarding a port from
the device onto my
local machine.
So I can start accessing
things.
This port number here, 9222,
that's what I can access just
in my browser, just in Chrome
on the desktop.
And you see there it's going
to show me The Guardian."
Click that.
And now I've just got the
developer tools, as you would
expect to see them
anywhere else.
Actually, if I'm going to do
some performance testing work
here, I think I've
made a mistake.
Because I've just opened a
standard tab on the browser.
But Addy you were saying
it's better to use
an incognito tab?
ADDY OSMANI: Yeah.
Whenever you're doing any sort
of performance profiling in
Chrome, it's generally best to
use a brand new incognito
window instead of using
a standard window.
Because any apps or extensions
you might have installed can
actually interfere with
the figures that
you're getting back.
So either run in incognito
mode, or start with a
completely blank
Chrome profile.
And that'll just make sure
that your figures are as
accurate as possible.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: So you get all
the tools that you're familiar
with on the desktop.
But you're looking at
a mobile device.
So if I look in the Timeline
here, what I'm going to do is
I'm going to start recording.
I'm going to refresh the page.
So we can capture what happens
on the first load.
And you can see things
coming through.
It will be just like it
is in the desktop.
But things will take longer.
Because it's a lower
power device.
I'll stop that there.
Let's have a look at some of the
stuff that "The Guardian"
did as they loaded.
So as you'd expect, I think
this was stuff that was
happening on the page before.
But here we go.
So this is where the
response kicks in.
You see some data.
The page starts building
itself.
If we have a look we'll see
eventually there is some
script evaluation.
So I'm not picking on "The
Guardian" because some kind of
issue with it, or anything.
Because it's actually
one of the
better performing websites.
They've done a really, really
good job of it.
I'm just showing some of the
things that maybe they could
improve upon if they wanted.
So if we have a look at this
script here, what do we see?
OK, so there's a lot of HTML
parsing happening on DOM load.
So this bit of JavaScript here
is taking up 300 milliseconds.
And a lot that is
HTML parsing.
This is little chunks of
text being sent to--
[INAUDIBLE].
It's something jQuery like,
because it's got a lot of the
methods you would expect
from jQuery.
But I expect it's maybe Zepto?
ADDY OSMANI: It's probably
something custom like Zepto.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: So if they
delivered all of these as one
lump to the parser, it would be
much quicker than doing it
in small parts.
And then they could pull out
the elements needed.
But as I say, they don't
really have a
huge performance problem.
But they could claw
back a few hundred
milliseconds by doing that.
So one of the things in the
beta is we get some of the
features from the desktop.
And one of those is
paint rectangles.
So if I click this cog in the
bottom right hand corner, I
get this menu.
And one of the things we'll
see in here is Show Paint
Rectangles.
So if we look at the device,
what happens here is anything
that's being repainted
is going to get a red
rectangle around it.
As you can see, it's only
really the scroll bar.
Because that's being drawn every
time I scroll the page.
The reason I'm not seeing any
paints around here is because
it's all already been painted.
It gets painted when
it's loaded.
And we're just sort
of panning up and
down it as we're scrolling.
That keep things really
nice and fast.
If I scroll to the top here
and click this Top Stories
button, you can see that
flash of red there.
Because it's had to draw that
region of the screen.
You can see that
here, as well.
So if I get rid of those--
I'm going to get rid of the
Paint Rectangles here.
Another one of the things we
can see as well is the
composited layer borders.
And this will show us what's
being sent as an extra layer
to the GPU.
On the show two weeks ago we
talked about what's going to
cause a layer, and what the
benefits of it are, what maybe
some of the downsides are.
So if I press that here we can
see that a grid has appeared
on the page.
And this is because the page
will be split into small
sections, and sent to
textures on the GPU.
And each one of the squares is
another part of the texture.
And as I zoom in, that grid
will adjust itself.
And you can see it's blurry.
And then the grid updates.
It becomes sharp again.
You can see that process
happening.
So anything that's on its
own layer gets an orange
rectangle around it.
And as you can see there's
nothing really on "The
Guardian" page that does that.
If we scroll right down
to the bottom here,
there is one here.
You can see this orange border
around this section here.
So let's take a look at
why that's happening.
If we bring the frames per
second meter up as well, this
gives you a clue to the GPU
memory situation, which is
really interesting.
You can see there,
18 megabytes.
We're not using a lot
on this page.
Let's find out why
that element's
formed it's own layer.
The easiest way to do that
is in the Elements panel.
I'm going to click this
magnifying glass here.
I click that.
And then I can just
tap somewhere
on the device itself.
So click there.
It's showing me that element.
If I go up to the UL, I can
see I had [? the styles ?]
there.
Nothing obvious in the
Nav, nothing there.
Here we go.
So in this section's footer,
there's this null transform.
So that's not really changing
the appearance of the page.
But it is triggering a layer
to be created here.
Not quite sure why they've
done that.
It's maybe working around a
bug in another browser.
It's been known to sort of
change how rendering happens
and improve things
in some browsers.
We can see we're using
18, 19 megabytes.
If I were to take that off and
total the page, we've just
freed up some GPU memory.
We're down to 16 megabytes.
So that's something they
could do as well.
But once again, I stress they
don't really have a huge
performance problem.
Even though they've got layers,
they don't need it.
It's not a big deal.
When we've got the frames per
second monitor here-- what I'm
going to do is take the
compositing off.
There we go.
So the frames per second only
updates as I'm scrolling.
Because nothing's being drawn
once I stop scrolling.
So the frames per second meter
is going to stay still.
You can see is we're scrolling
we're achieving near on 60
frames per second, which
is the ideal.
That's the refresh rate
of the device.
In the last session we were
talking about some of the
benefits of adding layers.
Like how it speeded
up animation.
But it's not always
a good thing.
So I'm going to try and
break the page.
I'm going to get rid of this
frames per second monitor.
And I'm going to give
everything on the
page its own layer.
And to do that, the simplest
way, I'm going to try and
spell the word, document.
I'm going to create
a style element.
And in a text content for
that I'm going to
do for every element.
And WebKit transform.
Do watch if I spell
anything wrong.
Because I'm dreadful at this.
ADDY OSMANI: This is genuinely
the first piece of coding that
Jake's done all year.
So don't worry if it looks
a little bit crap.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Started
Google and that's it.
Not allowed to code anymore.
And I'm going to do
translate Z, 0.
This time I'm going to put some
semicolons in just to mix
it up a bit.
So we're still--
if I can stop highlighting over
an element, we should
still have some really smooth
scrolling going on here.
Yeah, that's still smooth.
Because although I've created
that style element, it's not
in the document yet.
So I'm going to do
document.appendChild--
am I spelling that right?--
C-H-I-L-D.
This is going to add that script
to the page, and make
everything it's own layer.
I'm just going to keep
scrolling the page.
You can see it's smooth.
And now I'm going to add that
element to the page.
And that will take effect
in a second.
Actually, you can't do
document.appendChild.
That's a silly thing to do.
It's document.head.appendChild.
This is why I don't
do live shows.
So buttery smooth scrolling.
And then that goes into
the document.
And there we go.
We can see the scrolling, the
performance is just going
completely down the toilet.
It's awful.
ADDY OSMANI: And the reason
for that is that the link
between CPU and GPU
doesn't really
have a lot of bandwidth.
And so when you introduce
excessive textures there, it's
just going to look crap.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Exactly that.
If we bring the frames per
second meter, it shows us
exactly what's going on here.
It tells us the framework has
gone down to 25 or less.
But the real clue here
is the GPU memory.
We're hitting the top
of the GPU memory.
So as you scroll down the page,
things are going out of
GPU memory.
Other things are coming in.
We're losing all the performance
that we would get
from the hardware.
It's a terrible thing to do.
We can see now, if we put the
composite add layer borders
on, you see everything has that
orange border to show
that it's in a layer.
All we would need to do to get
our performance back is in the
dev tools, change that
to removeChild.
So scrolling bad, and that
will take effect.
And it will be a little bit of
time before it realizes I can
actually flush the GPU memory.
And everything should
come back to normal.
There we go.
So everything is smooth again.
Be careful with your layers.
Make sure you're not
creating too many.
But they can be really good for
certain bits of animation
performance.
Make sure you're testing
on the device.
Make sure you're looking
at the GPU memory.
Don't overuse it.
Because you will lose a lot of
performance in other places.
ADDY OSMANI: Ideally make sure
that you have a measurably
high repaint cost on something
before you start exploring
using these kinds of hacks.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Addy, what are
you going to talk about?
ADDY OSMANI: I've
got some toys.
So there have recently been
some really nice new tools
that have come out for
mobile debugging.
And I'm going show you something
called MIHTool, or
M-I-H tool, that basically gives
you an entire WebKit
Inspector on an iPad
or iPhone.
So we're going to switch
around a little bit.
We're going to do a--
JAKE ARCHIBALD: We're
going to do a swap.
ADDY OSMANI: We're going
to do a swap.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Well
this is the thing.
This studio only has one camera
next to me with the
mobile device on.
And I've got this machine
all networked up.
This is something we
couldn't do live.
Because we're actually going
to have to swap seats.
But we're going to
edit this in.
ADDY OSMANI: Yes.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: It's going
to look really smooth.
ADDY OSMANI: It's going
to look amazing.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: It is.
Maybe we should have some
animation where it morphs.
If we look at the camera, could
we have something that
was morph our faces?
I don't think we've got
time to do that.
ADDY OSMANI: We might.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Let's just
have a awkward fumble.
Hello, and welcome back to
Mobile Web Thursdays.
I'm Addy Osmani.
And with me in the studio is--
ADDY OSMANI: Jake Archibald.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: So you're going
to be showing some toys
you brought in?
ADDY OSMANI: Yes.
So I brought in an iPad today.
And I'm going to be showing you
a brand new tool called
MIHTool that helps you debug
apps and sites directly on
your iOS devices.
And one of the cool things about
this is that you get
both an inspector
on the device.
But you can also get things like
timeline for inspecting
what your performance is like,
what your scripting is like.
You get access to complete
cache control.
So if you want to make sure
that your pages are being
properly cached, and you just
see how your pages perform
there, you can do that
on the device, too.
So I'm going to switch over
to the iPad right now.
And I currently have
the site called--
this is a jQuery plug-in
site called Isotope.
You've probably seen
this before.
It's by Dave DeSandro.
It just organizes things.
It's this really nice layout
that's pretty flexible.
Jake, you were talking
about composited
layer borders earlier.
I'm going to go.
And I'm going to, first
of all, enable the Web
Inspector on here.
And the first thing you're going
to notice happen is that
I now have dev tools slash
a Web Inspector on here.
I can go and I can
inspect elements.
I have a resources panel.
I've got network.
I've got timeline.
And I can basically use these
in the same way that I do on
desktop dev tools.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Is a
native app running?
ADDY OSMANI: This is a native
app that's running.
And it's available for
iPhone and iPad.
Something I'm interested in is
whether this page is actually
using composited layer borders,
whether this will
work with composited layer
borders on, to see if any of
the elements on this page
are being promoted.
And I can actually I go into
the menu for this app, and
trigger WebKit Debug
Borders on.
I'm going to need to restart
the app really quickly.
So I'm just going to do that.
Back into MIHTool.
And now, I know it's
very, very subtle.
You probably can't
see it, actually.
But we do have the exact same
tiles on this page that Jake
was showing you earlier.
What you'll also have
are basically
these little outlines.
So let me zoom in
on an element.
And what you'll see around many
of these elements on the
page is that they have the same
highlight around them.
It should be yellow.
But in this case it's a
little bit more green.
But basically that means that
all these elements that have
that border around them
are being promoted
to composite layer.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Does that have
the thing where each tile is
given the number of times
it's being redrawn?
ADDY OSMANI: Actually, yes.
This is a feature that's
actually in the WebKit
Nightlies, if I'm correct.
And you get this right
with a MIHTool.
So you can get this on
your mobile device.
So I'm going to enable WebKit
Repaint Counter.
I'm going to restart the app
once again, very quickly.
And now what you can see-- you
probably saw it as a flash.
But what you can see, and we
can zoom in on a specific
block of the page, but around
every single element we now
have this little counter in
the corner, that basically
tells you the repaint counts
for that layer.
And if I scroll up and down,
these numbers will go up in
some cases, depending
on what's going on.
I just closed out of the
app accidentally.
But these numbers have basically
gone up in some
cases because of repainting.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: I'm no fan of
Safari's Web Inspector.
I don't understand how
the icons work.
It confuses me.
But check out the WebKit
Nightlies.
And check out this tool.
Because they've done
some really
excellent work around it.
There's a lot of stuff that
we're looking at with Web
Inspector going, we could have
some of those ideas.
ADDY OSMANI: There's
some really
interesting ideas in there.
And you also get access
to things like
Full User Agent setting.
So I can go and I can set this
to Firefox, or Chrome, or IE,
or whatever I want, basically,
without having to go back and
forth between my desktop
and my device.
So it means you get to debug
stuff more so on an actual
device, rather than having to
emulate it somewhere else,
which is neat.
But MIHTools has also got some
additional features you might
find useful.
If you go to View Source in
here, you'll actually get a
complete editor.
I probably want to turn off
those composited layer borders
very quickly.
I'm just going to
restart that.
I still have the repaint
counts on.
It doesn't matter.
But if I go to View Source, this
complete view here, you
might think that it's
just read only.
But I can actually go and make
changes to this page.
Which will then be previewed in
real time once I go back.
So I can make changes to this
any way that I want, the same
way that you probably make
changes to scripts or styles
inside the dev tools.
And the author of MIHTool
is a guy named Unbug, so
twitter.com/unbug.
And he's currently putting a
lot of work into improving
this editor.
So that you can basically go
wherever you want, make live
changes to your site or your
app, and preview what it's
like, and debug directly
on the device.
Which I think is neat.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: So I presume
that's using a WebView to show
you the page.
ADDY OSMANI: Yes, this
is using a WebView.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Does that
mean it's going to be--
because Safari, they have
some kinds of JavaScript
acceleration are only available
to the native
browser and not WebViews.
That's the case here?
ADDY OSMANI: There are some
limitations here.
When it comes to performance
profiling, that is going to be
one thing that you have
to keep in mind.
This is still using WebView.
It's not going to be completely
accurate when it
comes to using Timeline for your
performance profiling.
But for things like getting
insights into your composite
layer borders, getting insights
into those repaints,
it's actually cool.
Another useful thing you can
do with this is you can
actually remote into this tool,
and drive it from your
desktop if you want to.
I don't have a full set
up for this on my
screen at the moment.
But if we switch back to my
screen, I do have a screen
shot of this working earlier.
But basically I can control this
the exact same way that
Jake was doing earlier with
remote debugging to control
the device.
And you can actually send this
a bunch of commands.
You can send this URLs that
you want it to load up.
You can inject scripts
into there.
You can do a bunch of stuff.
It's definitely worth
checking out.
We'll link you up to MIHTool
in the show notes.
But the next thing I'm going
to be talking about is some
mobile emulation tools that we
have inside the dev tools.
Now for anybody that has done
any amount of mobile debugging
and mobile development before,
one pain point is actually
having to have these kinds
of devices around to
properly debug on.
And not everybody
has got those.
We've got a Nexus around here.
We've got Nexus 4 phones.
We've tons of devices.
Most people don't actually have
their own private lab for
this stuff.
So sometimes it can be useful to
have mobile emulation tools
available to you.
So you can just get this stuff
done inside your browser.
And we've put a lot of work into
doing this in Chrome via
the dev tools, lately.
The first thing I'm going to
show you is, let's say that
you're working on an
app or a site.
And you just want to be able
to preview what your
breakpoints look like.
Let's say I'm using
media queries.
And I want to see, what does my
site look like at different
viewport sizes.
Go into Dock-To-Right mode.
I'm currently in Dock-To-Right
mode.
Let's just kill the dev
tools very quickly.
I'm going to go back
into my dev tools.
This is probably what
you start out with.
Just hold and toggle
in the very corner.
And you can then switch
to Dock-To-Right mode.
And you can then use
the splitter.
So I'm going to be moving my
splitter more to the left.
And what you can see as I do
that is that the layout-- this
is "The Boston Globe"--
the layout is actually changing
every single time I
hit a different breakpoint.
And that means that I can just
preview what the site looks
like at different breakpoints.
Normally what some people have
been doing is actually
resizing Chrome.
You don't have to do that.
You can just use this.
And it'll do the exact
same thing.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Because
Chrome has a minimum
width to it, as well.
ADDY OSMANI: It does as well.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: It's
not a problem here
where you can go--
ADDY OSMANI: With this there's
not that issue.
I can go as far back
as I want.
I highly doubt-- at least now
until people get watches that
are running WebKit on them--
you'll be doing that.
But this is pretty useful for
those workflows where you do
want to just check out and make
sure your breakpoints are
looking OK.
Speaking of mobile emulation,
I'm going to go back
into to Full View.
We've put a lot of effort into
improving the mobile emulation
tools inside Chrome.
And if we go back into the
Settings cog that Jake was
showing you earlier, you're
probably going to land in
General by default.
Switch on over to the
Overrides tab.
And you'll get access to a whole
range of different tools
for emulating things.
At the very top what you
can see is User Agent.
You then have Device Metrics,
Geolocation, Device
Orientation, Touch Events,
and CSS Media.
So I'm going to show you some
of these in action.
So we're on "The Boston Globe."
I'm going to go, and
I'm going to emulate
my user agent to
something like iPhone.
Now what you'll notice is that
automatically that's actually
triggered my device metrics
to be changed.
And this is really useful for
a workflow that lets you
preview what your device
viewport might look like on
those devices.
So what you'll see--
let me close out of there and
just show you this view a
little bit more.
Basically this is around the
same size as an iPhone might
look like from a metrics
point of view.
But I can easily go and change
the orientation that I'm in.
So I can go from this
to this very easily.
I can go, and I can set custom
settings for my screen
resolution, if I want.
I'm also able to change my
settings for font scale.
So if a device has got a
particular font scale that you
want to emulate, you can also
easily go in and change that.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: What you'd want
to do there with working
with the iPhone, the numbers
that are in there are the
number of device pixels, not
the number of CSS pixels.
ADDY OSMANI: Exactly.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: So you probably
want to half those at
the moment.
ADDY OSMANI: Probably, yeah.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Something we're
working on at the moment
is emulating device pixel ratio
correctly in the browser.
But that hasn't landed yet.
ADDY OSMANI: That hasn't
landed yet.
It's hopefully going to in
the next few months.
But it's been a feature we're
getting a lot of requests for.
As mentioned, there are
a ton of different
options inside here.
At the moment, you've got
BlackBerry, Android 2.3, the
Nexus S. You've got Firefox.
You've got IE 9.
And this just means that rather
than having to go and
open up a complete device or
throw open an emulator, you
can just do this stuff inside
of dev tools, which can save
you some time.
The next thing I'm going to
show you is Geolocation.
Why don't we look at that.
Remy Sharp put together this
nice little Geolocation demo
that basically says, if your
device supports providing you
some sort of location, when
I load up this page it's
basically going to
try finding me.
And it's going to display
a Google Map
that shows my location.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: It's
done pretty well.
ADDY OSMANI: Yeah, it's
So we're currently on Bonhill
Street at Campus London.
And it seems to have roughly
found where we are correctly.
There are, however, going to be
times when you're working
on an international application
that's going to
need to perhaps be able to
show some custom content,
depending on where your
user is based.
So how do you debug that?
You can't take your device and
fly over to Spain just to
preview what that looks like.
It just wouldn't make sense.
So we've got this nifty little
feature that actually allows
you to override your geolocation
settings.
So what I'm going to do now is
I'm going to go and just
enable Geolocation.
And I've actually preset
my latitude and
longitude to something.
So I'm now going to just
refresh this page.
And it's placed me
somewhere else.
This is a custom location.
And why don't we just
zoom into this?
So zoom, zoom, zoom.
What's that?
We're now at the Batman
Dental Practice.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: It's not
the dentist you need.
It's the dentist you deserve.
This is in West London.
It's brilliant.
I love it.
ADDY OSMANI: I can't believe
there's a place that has a
Batman Dental Practice.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: I just put
Batman into Google Maps.
It's surprising how many places
are named after our
caped crusader.
If you need to find out the
lat, long of a particular
place, easiest way to do that
is to go into Google Maps.
Actually, can we get
my screen up?
Is that possible for a moment?
All you need to do is if you
right-click somewhere.
And you click What's Here.
And then the numbers that are
up here, that'll be the lat
long of the place you
right-clicked.
So if you're trying to test a
particular place in the world,
that's the quickest way to get
the lat long of that place.
ADDY OSMANI: Excellent.
Now sometimes you're also going
to want to be able to
preview what it's like if you
don't have geolocation
available at all.
So when I don't have my position
available, I can
actually just go and enable
another option.
So emulate position
unavailable.
And if I go and I refresh this
page again, what you can see
is that find your location
has failed.
And that's just another nice
little debug thing that can
help you with trying to figure
out, do I display a specific
message to my users saying, we
couldn't find your position?
Do we fall back on
something else?
But that's just another little
helper that you can use for
geolocation apps.
The next thing I'm going
to talk about is device
orientation.
So device orientation is
basically what we're talking
about when I'm moving my
device in different
directions, tilting, forward,
backwards, all that fun stuff,
as our model, Jake,
is showing off.
But there's a nice little helper
for this in the dev
tools as well.
So I'm going to go to
a new tab with a
different demo on it.
So this is a HTML5 Rocks demo
that has got device
orientation stuff set up.
And we're just going to see what
happens when I change my
device orientation.
So back into overrides.
Override device orientation.
Now we should probably explain
right before we start playing
around with these values.
So here you see alpha,
beta, and gamma.
So alpha corresponds to
the direction in which
your device is facing.
Beta is the front
to back tilt.
And gamma corresponds to
the left to right tilt.
What that means is if I go to
beta, and I perhaps change the
value to something like 60, and
go to gamma, what you'll
see is that it's instantly
changed.
That basically corresponds to
me doing this on my device.
Now I can also go to my gamma,
and I can change that.
Let's try changing that
to 60 as well.
What that's done it is it's
altered the device tilt, so
basically that.
And just being able to change
these values directly inside
of dev tools is so much easier
than having to open up your
app directly on the device, and
figure out, am I in the
right direction?
Is this working?
It's a really, really useful
workflow helper.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: I seem to
remember some suggestion that
we might do something a little
bit better with that
interface, maybe something
in 3D?
ADDY OSMANI: None of
this is final.
But we've been playing around
with some different mock-ups
for how we can improve this.
Because right off the top of my
head, I could not remember
the alpha, beta and gamma.
So it's just not going
to happen.
And so we've been thinking
about, what if we had some
sort of visual way, like a 3D
box, or something, directly
inside the tools.
So that when you change these
values, it's possible for you
to easily see, this is the
direction in which
my devices is now.
This is how it corresponds to
what my app would be doing.
So that's coming on.
We'll see if we end up landing
anything like that.
But it's just another useful
mock-up that we've been
kicking around.
So the next thing that
I'm going to talk
about are touch events.
So I've got a little demo
for that as well.
Touch events are something
particularly useful to emulate.
Because again, you don't
necessarily want to be pulling
out a device every single time
you want to just test the
things you're working.
And if you've got your app, and
it's supposed to working
fine on desktops, it's supposed
to be working fine on
mobile, something you can
actually do is just go back
into your overrides and
emulate touch events.
Now before I go and emulate
this, I'm going to show you a
quick demo.
So this is a paint demo
by Paul Irish
and a few other folks.
And the general idea is I go
into this canvas area.
And I start moving
my cursor around.
And I should be able to
draw inside here.
Unfortunately, this demo only
works with touch events.
It's sort of optimized
for touch.
And I can't do anything in here,
unless I'm on an iPad or
a Nexus device.
So I go and I emulate
my touch events.
And what that basically means
is that I can just use my
cursor to emulate things
like ontouchstart,
ontouchend, and so on.
And I can actually, hopefully,
draw in here now.
There we go.
It's working.
This is just going
to look so bad.
It's like the worst
thing ever.
But it works.
It works.
What's also helpful is, if I
now go back to my Sources
panel, and I go to Event
Listener Breakpoints in the
sidebar-- let me expand
that a little bit.
I scroll down.
You'll see one expandable
called Touch.
And in here you'll see Touch
Start, Touch Move, Touch End,
and Touch Cancel.
Now let's say that I want to set
breakpoints on Touch Start
and Touch Move.
What happens now is, if I try
drawing inside here, it's
going to pause inside
of the debugger.
Because it's detected that
I'm either running
one of those events.
And it's just detected that
we want to stop there.
And this is useful because it
means that, again, rather than
having to be on an actual
device, I can just do the
stuff inside of dev tools, and
have a complete debugging
workflow, using the tools
that I'm used to
using, which is nice.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: If we can switch
to my screen for a
moment, a project by one of
our colleagues, Boris.
If you're interested in hacking
around with something,
this is a really good project
to look at, Magic Touch.
So this is using a
variety of tools.
And what it will let you do is
convert your touch pad on your
Mac, if you have one.
And it will send those
multi-touch
events into the browser.
So you can use the touch
pad the same way you
would a phone service.
And it puts those events
to the browser.
It's a little bit of work
to get it set up.
But if you've got to some spare
time to have a hack
around, it's a fun
thing to do.
And if anyone wants to do some
pull requests, you can teach
Boris how to write some HTML.
That would be very beneficial
to Boris and Google.
ADDY OSMANI: Excellent.
So while it's not necessarily
related to mobile, the second
to last thing I'm going
to be showing you is
CSS print style emulation.
So I'm going to go back inside
the dev tools and overrides.
The very last option is
Emulate CSS Media.
I guess not a lot of people
are going to be using it.
But it's useful for you if you
want to preview what, say,
your print stylesheet looks like
without having to go to
hack around the DOM and hack
around your different
stylesheets.
So I go here.
And I emulate CSS Media.
I'm on "Smashing Magazine." And
what you can now see is
that it's completely switched
the styles in this page over
to something that can actually
look decent in print.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: I didn't realize
they had print styles.
That's really nice.
ADDY OSMANI: It's one of the few
sites I was able to find
that actually has them.
But this is really useful.
"Smashing" is one of those sites
where you might want to
actually print out articles if
you don't necessarily have a
device you're carrying
around the place.
But it's another little helper
that can just avoid you having
to do too much extra
stuff just to
preview your print styles.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Does our
emulation cover the way when
things print they don't tend
to print backgrounds?
Is that covered there?
Or is it just switching
the stylesheet?
ADDY OSMANI: I think this is
just switching the stylesheet.
Again, fewer sites actually
use these.
You can preview what a site
using Braille might do for
that, that specific stylesheet,
or screen, or
speech, or TV, and so on.
It's useful.
The last thing I'm going to
show you is a little demo
using Browser Stack.
So Browser Stack, I'll
just quickly pull
it up on the screen.
Browser Stack is this really
awesome site that lets you
test things in the cloud.
So if, for example, you're an
app developer that wants to
see how their site or app
looks like in Ice Cream
Sandwich on a specific mobile
phone, or iOS 5 on a specific
Apple device, and you don't have
the money or the funds or
the time to go plugging in these
different devices, and
you don't necessarily want to
be using emulators, you can
just use Browser
Stack for this.
They've got a ton of different
devices hooked up, a ton of
different emulators that are
just running in the cloud.
And you can just spin up
different instances of those
whenever you want.
What I've actually done for
my dotfiles is I've
just wired them up.
So I can actually just easily
execute any site, whether it's
local or external, via a
specific combination.
In this case, which you can see,
it says Android Nexus.
And I want to go see what "The
Boston Globe" looks like on
latest Android version
on a Nexus device.
And that's basically going to go
and spin up Browser Stack.
It should roughly take
just a moment.
This is the part where it
just fails colossally.
It's working, maybe.
Maybe it's opening something.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Cameras
do have a habit of
breaking any demos.
ADDY OSMANI: They do.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: But I find
this tool really useful.
A couple weeks ago I was working
from home, because it
had snowed.
And if you can't work
from home when
it's snowing outside--
ADDY OSMANI: Snow is Jake's
general excuse for
not being at work.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: But I was
writing an article about
script loading.
Ad we had the suspicion that
maybe there was a time when
one spec came in.
One spec was changed.
And we were worried that maybe
there was a crossover period
that might be on some
Android devices.
And I was at home.
I only have one Android
device.
Well, I've got two.
But they're both running ICS.
So just being able to spin this
up, and just be able to
go through loads of devices,
loads of different Android
versions, iOS versions
to see what was
going on, it was great.
You can't test performance
sensitive things.
ADDY OSMANI: Performance is a
tricky thing, too, to test.
And we've been speaking to
Browser Stack about this.
And apparently one thing that's
on their radar is being
able to remotely use your dev
tools to inspect pages.
So I might be using my local
dev tools, call out to a
Browser Stack instance, and
actually be able to see
performance profiling, real
time, on an actual device.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: So although you
wouldn't be able to see
what was happening with the
performance, in terms of the
phone updating, you would get
the accurate information from
the Timeline.
ADDY OSMANI: Exactly yeah.
Actual data, which is actually
really, really fascinating.
Browser Stack also have a ton
of developer tools that can
you can use on many
of these devices.
I'm not sure how well
those interact
with some of the emulators.
But they're constantly doing
a lot of work in the mobile
space to try improving
testing in the cloud.
And I think it's just, again
for those people that don't
necessarily have a local device
lab, it's genuinely
useful for your testing
workflow.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Thats
really neat.
Excellent.
Well, thank you for joining us
in this Mobile Web Thursday
Extravaganza.
Do you think we can call
it extravaganza?
ADDY OSMANI: I think
this has been a
colossal failure, if anything.
We can call it--
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Let's
reach a compromise.
And we'll call it a Colossal
Extravaganza.
ADDY OSMANI: There we go.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: And so next
Thursday there will be someone
else sitting here, talking
about something else.
I haven't actually
looked it up.
But you should tune
in for that.
Because I'm sure it will
be absolutely amazing.
Thank you very much, guys.
Bye bye.
ADDY OSMANI: Bye.